Hãy hả bị mốt thằng tảm bộ của phần ngà thông báo, hạ độ thảy bình dương là tiếng hành loạt hoạt động diễn tập trên biển Nhật Bản.
Trong đó, toàn hộ về Mashau Shappers Nicole, phóng tự tự tự hành trình, k lưu ở trong hàng uan,
nhằm kiểm tra khả năng tấn công các mục tiêu trên biển.
Ngoài các vụ phóng tự lửa lực lượng hạ con ngà cũng trên khai nhiều mấy bây và thí bị bây không người lấy,
tụ vụ hả lựa tắc chiến sám sát và đánh giá hiệu quả hoạt động của sư.
Hình anh được bộ của phần ngà công bố cho thấy quy mô của cuộc tập trận lên này.
Bộ được đánh giá là nhằm cùng cố khả năng sẵn sản chình đấu của hạm độ thảy bình dương.
Cung ngay người đứng đau tập đoan năng đường hạp nhân nhận nước ngà, Rosatoom,
ông Alicelli khách chết cho rằng Mashau và Kân định những tính trình hiện đại hoá là chảnh hạp nhân
để uống phóng viên mối đây soạn ninh ngày càng lớn.